à à
anh Alo ạ
ừ ừ
anh alo
Chào các bạn
Mình ở đây từ 7 giờ rồi mình làm khá sốt
ruột để muốn dậy sớm vậy Thực ra là tầm
từ 7 giờ đủ đi thì mình mình đang làm
việc mình cứ cảm thành kiểu chóng 5 nó
kiểu luôn luôn nước nôn gì nhé
cho dù Mặc Tử
Anh Trung ơi kiu trong lòng hiểu kiểu
dáng kiểu hức kiểu gì gì đó thì ra là
mình cũng không thể tập trung làm việc
nữa
nhưng mà ăn sớm như này được ra là cũng
chẳng biết nói gì Vì
mình à
cho mình xem cái câu hỏi girl à trong
trong cái
mình mình đang phân biệt rõ cái câu hỏi
khi mà hỏi ở bên web và khi hỏi bên exel
Hỏi bé queo thì các bạn trong video
trong mấy buổi video thì các bạn không
Đang câu hỏi mấy mà chủ yếu các bạn cũng
hỏi về Apple nhiều ở trên kênh đi cốt
thì mình có trả lời hết mình cậu ấy cũng
như mình có giải thích các thứ rồi các
bạn để xem qua mấy câu đấy giống ở đây
này Có mấy câu AK mình vừa nãy mình lại
vừa hỗ trợ thêm một bạn về cái vụ cao
Extra Cường như thế này chẳng hạn Nếu mà
nói thế không phải là các bạn nên kiểu
liên tục và ai ngờ mình giải bài tập
khi đặt câu hỏi ở đâu á thì các bạn cứ
hỏi ở trên buổi livestream này này thì
nếu mà mình không trả lời được ở trên
buổi livestream tại thời điểm đấy Từ lúc
mình đang dậy thì mình sẽ luôn xem lại
mọi video để mà xem mình bỏ lỡ cái bình
luận nào của các bạn không ạ mình sẽ ghi
lại hết ở đây đều mình sẽ trả lời nhưng
mà vì bên web các bạn ấy Họ nhiều hỏi
nói chung và ở bên đấy là đông hơn để họ
nhiều hơn họ bên này cho toàn anh an
toàn con này người ta gỡ học giỏi sẵn
rồi chẳng cần hỏi gì cả nha cậu bên kênh
e kia này mình thấy Exciter bơ tầm tầm
người cũng tương đương ấy cũng hơn 100
người thôi không hỏi là đông lắm nhưng
bên web thì họ họ nhiều hơn còn bên
Apple này dường như là kẹo em mình khùng
mình mình chỉ ngại nhất và nóng nhất là
các bạn xe máy ở đấy em kiểu học online
mình mình thực tế mình đang học mà lại
đô thị như thế mà kiểu
đi xe máy ở đấy điểm cho anh rồi đi chỗ
khác mình mình mình không muốn các bạn
làm như thế vì mình không quan tâm gì
được có bao nhiêu người đang xem
Ừ mình quan tâm Thực sự là các bạn đang
có lắng nghe thức không đúng à thì các
bạn cách để học tốt nhất thì các bạn vừa
lắng nghe các bạn phải đặt câu hỏi liên
tục kiểu tha ma liên tục và có lớp mình
sẽ trả lời được ngay trong buổi
livestream vào lúc thì mình sẽ đề tài
của họ để rồi sao trả lời như thế này để
ngon thì nó sẽ ổn hơn
để tui nhìn các bạn nhìn kiểu bên này
hỏi Nhiều kinh khủng thế này chẳng hỏi
gì cả mà thực ra là có nhiều câu bên này
thì mình có thể trả lời được có trong
buổi này Nhưng mà mình lại muốn
cậu bởi vì lỡ đặt câu hỏi ở bên bên kia
rồi nên là mình sẽ trả lời Bên kia chẳng
ạ và thực ra thì cũng là nhược điểm
nghĩa có những bạn mà chỉ học SQL thì sẽ
không nghe được câu hỏi em nghe câu trả
lời của mình ở bên web Đấy lý do mà mình
chia cái video của video của Bùi mình
luôn là đầu video mình sẽ luôn trả lời
các câu hỏi chẳng hạn để Nếu được sự các
bạn mà chỉ muốn học were thôi nha bạn
muốn trả lời nói cái câu mình cái câu
này ở bên web thì các bạn cứ vào vào
kênh của mình xong rồi vào bên video bến
quá em buổi sau mình sẽ trả lời tất cả
những câu này sang lại nóng Ê có vài câu
ở đây mình thấy khá là hay này ờ ờ
Xin
Kiểu đại khái bạn này hỏi là kiểu bạn ấy
mua một cái phần mềm sau đó đi gì hết 15
Tại sao nó không dùng nữa đấy thì thì
mình sẽ giải đáp cho bạn đấy Chính xác
là về vấn đề về
bản quyền
Lysin nóng hoa mà quyền và
Kỳ Cùng các thứ cũng nhờ crack Tại sao
lại crack được phần mềm đóng ngoặc thì
làm mình mình nghĩ là được ra có nhiều
bạn biết rồi mình còn không hả nào dân
chuyên mà cười rách
Ừ thì anh những bạn nào mà chuyên làm
cái vụ đấy cho hiểu hết rồi nhưng mình
cũng muốn nói qua cho những bạn nào mà
không phải dân công nghệ chẳng không tìm
hiểu sâu về cái đấy hoặc là chưa rồi
nghĩ về cái đấy chồng ạ Tại sao nó lại
như thế thì mình từng có cha Vừa mới cái
đấy thì mình mình sẽ ra bát cho các bạn
cái này trong buổi cậu ép thôi còn bộ
Acquy dao này thì
anh chẳng biết chứ gì mình có một cái
bài rất là hai này Nhưng mà mình nghĩa
phải đến cuối của hôm nay mình mới chia
sẻ
anh bởi vì bài bài hôm nay các bạn thấy
mục lục mới rất là ngắn giữa hàng ngàn
thôi nó vô CPU và và cái cái chia sẻ ở
cuối giờ này
Ừ đấy thì cái chia sẻ của Giờ này cũng
là một cái hai này theo kiểu là các bạn
hoàn toàn có thể là cho dù không học bên
web không ạ Các bạn có thể xanh mấy cái
video ở bên kênh web kiểu bên khóa học
web rồi Các bạn xem những cái chia sẻ ở
của video anh chia sẻ những cái câu trả
lời trả lời câu hỏi ở đầu video này và
những cái ghế chia sẻ ở cuối video Thế
có nhờ các bạn cũng cũng thích rồi đúng
không ạ cũng học người rất nhiều cái còn
về cái nội dung bài học thì nó là ở giữa
thì các bạn hoàn toàn thế không xem đúng
không ạ Mình có chia mục lục các thứ tôi
nghe các bạn hoàn toàn thể bỏ qua những
việc đấy
nghe hợp lý mà ông ạ
anh kia cái này cái này Tí mình sẽ chia
sẻ các bạn còn gì nữa nhỉ
Mình nghĩ là cho mắt thì các bạn cứ lên
luôn lên cái trang
này để và luôn xem lại đúng không em xem
lại
trận à
Ừ địt nhau à
ừ ừ
Chúc các bạn luôn lên tranh này để xem
xem buổi hôm nay sẽ học về cái gì cho từ
từ nữa đúng mặt
vì kiểu
Nếu như mình đã nói cái này nó là chuyên
sâu thế nên là nó sẽ không Hẳn nào giống
cơ bản tí là làm bài tập xong là hiểu
được ngay và còn nhớ hiểu là một chuyện
còn nhớ nữa đúng không
vì nó không đến nỗi là mút được khó hiểu
nhưng mà nói chung à Cái này nó bị rộng
chuyên sau rồi nó rất là rộng thành ra
các bạn làm các bạn à làm bài tập xong
các bạn có thể tự nghĩ ra đề làm thêm
này và nếu là cảm thấy chưa nhớ nữa lại
phải làm nhiều lần đúng không Cứu Thế
một tuần mình có một buổi cơm à thì
không thì kiến thức hôm nay của mình dậy
cô sẽ bu thời gian mình dậy khiến lớp
tận 237 liền Nhưng mà ở đây mình chỉ dạy
một buổi thôi một buổi nhưng mà riêng
Voice video này các bạn tí sẽ thấy nó
rất dài đấy nó có thể hơn Tiến đấy thì
Ừ thì các bạn mà chỉ làm mỗi bài tập
Thôi thì mình nghĩ là thực sự thì các
bạn khó mà nhớ khó hiểu được cái hay của
nó
từ bắt đầu từ buổi hôm nay toàn bộ những
ngày sau đều hai cực tất cả mấy cái điều
hay tình cảm thấy hồi đến mình giận thì
cái này nó rất là dễ à không phải dễ mà
rất là hay và kiểu cảm thấy
phấn chấn nhất kiểu dại mà Bởi vì mình
mình mình thấy kiến thức và rất là ổn để
mặt nhiều người cùng biết và tạm biệt là
các bạn Nói chung là sao cho để mà đến
cuối buổi học này ngồi trả lời được hết
mấy câu hỏi vấn đáp mày nghỉ à
Ừ được mà
thì các bạn hô đấy mình làm có khỏi cần
thì phần đáp này rồi tiếp bằng tiếng
Việt sau đó nhờ nhờ một bạn dịch cho
tiền ra tiếng Anh nó vẫn vợ một tí
để mà kiểu hỏi sinh viên Hồi đấy mình
mình cho cho đấy ở trường cho vui
à à
à
mình mình tự tin mình tự tin là mình sẽ
dạy cho các bạn odu2 checker
cho
mình cái đấy các bạn sẽ thấy rất dễ hiểu
và
Anh hiểu là một chuyện đúng a vẫn hiểu
là một chuyện đúng không ạ phải ở
ẩm thực hành nữa
Ừ cái soát sân này thì mình ít Hồi đấy
Mỹ dạy học sinh viên ở trong nước xuân
này thì ra giọng nên mình chỉ dạy các
bạn được cho các bạn thôi như còn chi cơ
vô CPU này hai cái mà mình làm việc rất
nhiều hồi đấy mình tìm hiểu rất sâu về
cái chi câu này chẳng ạ mình tin là hôm
đấy mình sẽ dạy các bạn thôi
Ờ Ờ mình từng dạy ở trường Belt thì các
bạn thời ra muốn chém muốn hỏi thông tin
cá nhân của mình thì tra trên trang cá
nhân mình sẽ ra hết rồi Ừ Bây giờ mình
tò mò tí mình chưa có mong thì mình thử
tra tên mình trên Google thì mở ra được
những gì Ồ nó ra được cái
ra được cả YouTube rồi này
ủng phết
anh
lên được mình 8.000 Tìm kiếm rồi hồi
trước rồi mấy được tầm 4.000 Đó nghĩa là
mình đấy mình khuyên các bạn mà mình
nhưng có một cái gọi là một cái minh lên
một cái biệt danh một cái chữ ký riêng
kiểu gì thế để các bạn vì sau bây giờ mà
Trang Nguyễn Long này thực sự mình không
mở lên được Cái trang nhất về thực sự
thì ai
giám đốc VNPT Không biết bao giờ tôi mới
có thể mượt kiểu ngày lấy kiểu như thế
thế nên là thế nên người ông vậy chơi
thêm biệt danh thôi tra theo tên Nếu
không bao giờ trên được mấy cái người
yêu sẽ cắt thử đầu u
à Có chứ đêm đêm đến mình cũng xem một
hai một hai giải đấu về rồi ta
a
cay Nhắc nhắc Thiện nói lại cái vụ là
kiểu mình có thường Bây giờ mình chưa
ghê ý thì mình chủ yếu mình chơi mày
game kia gọi là game moba game chiến
thuật để mà vừa chơi vừa có tí gọi là
rèn tư duy một tí đấy như là cái đấy nó
hơi Nhị Thiên hướng cho con trai vậy có
trai về các bạn nào thích bạo lực thích
kiểu các thứ giấy hơn nhưng mà như mình
đã nói rồi là các bạn không biết được
các game thủ game thủ Nói chung ấy thì
thì
sẽ cậu độ phản xạ của nó họ hơn họ tính
toán trong một giây nhanh hơn họ vi xử
lý nhiều thứ cùng một lúc có thể hướng
dẫn mình nghĩ là
thường là game thủ người ta cũng sẽ có
cái đầu óc nó nhanh nhanh mình thấy thế
không kiểu bị chậm chậm đấy
[âm nhạc]
Anh nói sự ra học một tuần một buổi như
thế này thì các bạn sẽ càng dễ quên nữa
vì nếu với các bạn làm bài tập ngay ngày
hôm sau đấy thì ra các bạn sẽ quên cục
cách cách làm của mình hồi mà mình đi
học với cách mình nhớ bài đó là trước
hôm đi trước hôm trước hôm học môn đấy
mình bắt đầu làm bài tập chung ngoài làm
bài tập ngay ngay tối mấy đó thì ngay
Tối hôm đấy mình con nhớ mạ thì chuẩn ra
là trước hôm đấy một ngày thì mình ngồi
đọc lại hết về làm bài tập đúng rồi Cái
này chia lô mình mới phải nốt thêm ở với
mình ghi lại rất nhiều Tab các từ từ
ở mình cho mình đi thêm ở đây là mình sẽ
chia sẻ thêm về
ở
những ứng dụng mình đang dùng cá cái này
mình từng chia sẻ rồi đấy nhưng mà ở
trên nhóm you tim chứ không như tính
công ty chứ không phải à
ở trong một khóa học kê
số của em quên
hai
tuần sau học
CS tuần này học xong Phong HM lời Gần
như chắc là xong rồi nó cho tuần sau
mình sẽ học sẽ hét ở bên bên Quách
à à
anh không Mình thức em lại không muốn
như vậy tập quá nhiều với tập quán nhìn
trong kiểu nó sợ ấy Kiểu mình bị lưỡi
nên là mình vẫn luôn cho lượng bài tập
chỉ để trong vòng 1 hoặc 2 tiếng các bạn
hoàn toàn thì làm xong 2 tiếng ở được ra
ở Quá nhiều luôn đấy trừ khi các bạn yếu
các bạn quân xử hết kiến thức các bạn
với cháu liên tục
còn không thì các bạn
Em chỉ cần mình nghĩa là chị chưa đến
một tiếng là có thể xong đống bài tập
đấy để không nói có sao nhé Còn à Có sao
đâu chưa Tùy theo mức độ các bạn cho dù
để các bạn hiểu được câu Sao không để
làm đúng không ạ
ờ ờ
bài tập về cái mấy bữa trước rồi các bạn
mấy cái bài tập đấy toàn chỉ là hết thôi
mà Thì nó rất là dễ không có thực hành
gì mấy nên là mình nghĩ là cho là một
đống bài tập thì các bạn cũng chỉ là gõ
đi Gõ lại thì câu lệnh crash trái nghĩa
gì cả
nhà thiết kế Làm sao để thiết kế một
database chọn ạ Đây là một câu hỏi rất
là hay theo kiểu đã rất nhiều người ở
từng hỏi và đến chính mình còn đang phải
luôn tự họ lại Thứ nhất là không có bất
ngờ khái niệm thế nào ở chuột em mình sẽ
thử ví dụ cho các bạn
ờ ờ
đây mình thử ví dụ cho các bạn nhé ạ
có một ví dụ rất là điển hình và mình
lúa não đầu với nó luôn trăn trở với nó
luôn đây giả sử là mình có bè sản phẩm
mã này tên này giá này sửa một iPhone
này iPhone Tàu Đấy nhá 10k anh nữa đúng
không
ờ ờ Giả sử là đương nhiên là sản phẩm
thì phải có hóa đơn đúng không hóa đơn
này mà đơn
sợ là mã tự động tăng này xong nó thì
thì ngày mua này trở lại đúng không sau
đó thì đương nhiên là một hóa đơn có thể
chứa nhiều sản phẩm Đúng không Một hóa
đơn
bằng nhiều sản phẩm
và một mặt hàng sản phẩm đúng không
ở một mặt hàng sản phẩm thì đương nhiên
là thuộc nhiều hóa đơn xe mối quan hệ
này mối quan hệ mờ hóa đơn bằng n sản
phẩm điều hòa
rất là mình sẽ tạo bảng trung gian lưu
cả hai mình sẽ có bảo hóa đơn chi tiết
mà
mình sẽ lưu lại mã hóa đơn này
và mã sản phẩm
và mình và nếu mình chỉ lưu mỗi thế này
thì mình không phải biết được là giả sử
Bây giờ thời sự là hóa đơn là một này
này mua là ngày hôm nay là ngày 20 tháng
ạ sau đó thì mình mua 33 cái phone tàu
em ạ thì mình không thể là mã hóa đơn 1
mã sản phẩm Một lập đi lập lại như này
ba lần được thế này thật ra không tốt
cho ngoan thì mình sẽ thêm một cột nữa
cột số lượng này
và cho hai cái hai cột này là khóa chính
ạ là sử mình bôi màu nó này ở lại
buôn màu nha
hai mẫu này nó hơi bị trói quá Em hãy
kiểu nhà hai cái này quá trình đúng
không Thì thì số lượng và ba chàng ạ sử
mình mua thêm một con Samsung nó ngon
xanh sung Mỹ ạ đúng không
Mỹ Tho ạ ra mi càng này
đấy thì cũng trong hóa đơn đấy là sự
mình cũng trong hóa đơn đấy đúng không
Thì vẫn làm mã hóa đơn là một mã sản
phẩm ở một đến mình chỉ mua được một con
thôi chẳng hạn thế Thì các bạn thấy là
nếu là sự mỗi mã hóa đơn mà khóa chính
đúng không Thì mã số mã hóa đơn không
được phép gặp lại đoạn này sửa lỗi thế
nên là bắt buộc phải hai cột này cùng
một khóa chính để hai cột này cùng lập
lại nó mới lỗi xử mình tự nhiên được
thêm tiền mình mua thêm một con Samsung
Mỹ Tho nữa thì mình mình không phải lặp
lại như này mà mình phải tăng số lượng
nên chẳng hạn đúng không ạ
ở đây là bài toán đơn giản
em chưa phải cái thiếu mình đang đau đầu
cái thứ mình đang ở đầu nó là như thế
này Ok Giả sử bây giờ các bạn trả lời
nhanh cho mình có mài động ra tổng tiền
hóa đơn của mình hiện tại là hóa đơn một
hệ thống hoặc tổng tiền là bao nhiêu
tiền ạ Bạn bạn nó giỏi toán tính hộ mình
Pháp
à à
có ai mình có thai là em một đúng không
tổng tiền của hóa đơn một này đang là
bao nhiu tiền
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi nghĩa là tại sao bạn ra được
con số 50 Quan trọng là tại sao ạ
các bạn phải nói lý do đúng không ạ Tại
sao nó ra lại gần con số 50 hẹn con số
50 con số may mắn à
phải sợ
Ừ bạn cứ trả lời đi rồi mình mới giải
thích đúng không ạ
x10x 30
a10x 30 sai gì không ạ
U20 cộng với 10 X3 Đúng rồi
nghĩa nghĩa nghĩa là đây Các bạn thấy
đúng rồi các bạn kia trả lời chuẩn này
phải chính xác mà không quan tâm về cái
số lấy một con thân mến nó số lượng này
đúng không các bạn nhân với cái giá lấy
từ đây từ đâu ạ Lấy từng mã sản phẩm để
nối xanh bản sản phẩm để lấy giá đúng
oặt số nhân với sau đó thì + + người hết
với nhau đúng không Trong một hóa đơn
này đều ngoan
Ừ đúng chưa ạ
Ừ chị đây bài toán nó lại như thế này nó
mà đơn giản như này thì anh sẽ quá
Ê mày toàn nó lại như thế này ạ thì
em giả sử tháng sau iPhone nó ra iPhone
mới nên iPhone cũ nó lại giảm giá nó
giảm dáng hình 5 đồng như này đỗ qua
shipper giá thì cái hóa đơn này lại có
tổng tiền là bao nhiêu ạ
hai cái hóa đơn này thì các bạn được này
nó tổng tiền hàng còn bao nhiêu
Ê Ê hình như mình đến chat nó bị trừ
à à
thì các bạn thấy thực ra là mình không
quan tâm về việc tổng tiền Đang còn là
bao nhiêu nữa các bạn chỉ thấy là bây
giờ chắc chắn tổng tiền khác với tổng
tiền cũ đúng oặt nếu mà khác như này thì
có phải là thằng thằng nào mà làm kế
toán thống kê tính toán rõ ràng là Hồi
trước tao Thu về tận 50 cho cái đơn này
Bây giờ tao tỉnh lại đôi này mất 35 cái
tao thu thừa của khác à Mẹ ra trả lại
khách à không đúng không ạ nghĩa là các
bạn thấy rõ ràng và cái này đang có vấn
đề là theo cậu lại giá này tự nhiên mình
thay đổi thành ra là là cái những cái
đơn cũ mà liên quan đến sản phẩm này
chẳng hạn đúng không Thì nó bị thay đổi
được ngon thì thế nên là mình không thể
lưu giá treo kiểu ngay được có 2 cách để
một mình lưu một là bởi vì giá đã thay
đổi tức là một sản phẩm có nhiều giá
đúng ạ khi mình phải tách cái cột giá
này sang bạn riêng và mình sẽ là
thì mình sẽ phải mình sẽ phải cậu dạng
là sản phẩm này tự người giá nào nhưng
nhưng mà như thế ở ra nó mày toàn nó hơi
phức tạp một tí thế nên là thường là
mình thường anh dậy sinh viên có cách
kiểu như thế này vẫn đúng nhá Nó vẫn
đúng này là là thứ nhất là mình sẽ lưu
lại giá khi mà giá bán
giá này chắc ạ thì mình sẽ lưu lại khi
mà lần đấy Mình bán bao nhiêu tiền thì
mình sẽ lưu lại như này đề về sau ra có
thay đổi thì giá cũ nó không được thay
đổi được ngoan thì nó sẽ vẫn giữ nguyên
được tổng tiền của cái đơn cũ nó không
làm ảnh hưởng gì cả đúng không thay đổi
ra đây thì bên không quan trọng nữa đúng
không Bởi vì giá đấy ạ ra dán này ra mới
còn già này là giá tại thời điểm mà mình
mua đồ ngoài thì thì đây là một cái
không phải là chuẩn của thiết kế cơ sở
dữ liệu bởi vì cái Rõ ràng cái này có
thể lấy được từ thằng từ thẳng sản phẩm
để lấy được một giá đấu à nhưng mình vẫn
phải lưu lại Bởi vì đây là lưu liên quan
đến lưu lại theo thời gian thời gian tại
thời điểm đấy đúng không Nhưng mà theo
quy tắc của chuẩn hóa cơ sở dữ liệu thì
cái này là sai bởi vì anh không không
được lưu khi nó thử ấy nó ngoan nó thừa
Khi mà giỡn hàng đã cái nó sẽ lấy từ bản
khác để mà ra được một đấy
Đêm các bạn hiểu bản chất chưa
Và đôi khi đôi khi ạ Các bạn vừa rồi Các
bạn thấy là vừa rồi để tính toán ra cái
tổng tiền đó nhà cứ mỗi lần mình tính
toán lại tổng tiền thì mình lại phải nối
từ bảo hóa đơn sang bảo hóa đơn hoặc là
hóa đơn chi tiết sau đó thì lấy số lượng
nhân với giá mà nếu mà giờ sử mà đơn đấy
thực là đơn đấy mà thanh toán xong thì
giá Nó gần như là không được cái tổng
tiền gần như không thay đổi nữa đúng
không mà cứ mỗi lần thao tác như thế
mình lại phải mất công tính toán ạ mình
lại phải bắt máy tính tính nên là đôi
khi ở một vài nơi điển hình là bây giờ
mình đang làm công ty nóng thế thôi đó
là mình lưu lại của tổng tiền ở đây và
mình sẽ quý ốp thẳng luôn này như thế
này chẳng ạ đề thi nếu vào khi nào mình
muốn lấy tổng tiền nhanh ạ thì mình chỉ
lấy tôi con này thôi cột này thì lấy từ
đâu từ lúc mà mình tính toán trước mấy
cái này rồi mình đi lại rồi đổ ngon Cái
này Thực ra là cái này là vi phạm quy
tắc của cái cái cái thiết kế cơ sở dữ
liệu như mình vừa nói đó là những cái mà
thể tính toán được khi mình không được
phép lưu lại mà mình sẽ phải mình sẽ
phải luôn tính free Bởi vì nếu Giả sử
dụng mình lỡ thay đổi ở trong này thành
con số khác thì phải tẩm phía này thành
sai đúng không Nhưng mà mang nói là bài
toán thực tế là gần như những cái này
không bao giờ thay đổi với một khi thanh
toán rồi các bạn tránh thay đổi cả đều
ngoan
ý thì cái này sẽ luôn cố định và cái này
cố định Mà mình lại mất công mỗi lần
mình lấy tổng tiền của một đơn ra mình
mất công tỉnh mạ đồng hoặc tại bắt máy
tính tĩnh lại thì ra thế nó hơi bị thừa
thì ra là cách đấy ạ nó luôn là bài toán
bản chất từ nãy giờ mình đã nói nó luôn
là bài toán về việc là
ở tốc độ
Em tính toán
gọi tốc độ xử lý tốc độ xử lý
với với
bộ nhớ lưu trữ
Cái này nó không mờ đi được với nhau dễ
lắm nếu mà các bạn muốn tốc độ xử lý
nhanh được như mình đang nói đó là hiển
thị ra được tổng tiền ra luôn thì các
bạn phải chấp nhận và lưu lại sẵn cả lúc
mà mình đã tính trước đấy Mình lưu lại
như này sẽ tốn bộ nhớ đúng không còn nếu
các bạn không muốn Tối muộn tốn bộ nhớ
mình muốn ít cột thôi đúng ạ thì mỗi lần
mỗi lần lấy cái gì ra các bạn lại mốc
tính lại chỉ gặp mất thêm thời gian để
mà đội cái điều đấy đúng không ạ
thời trang cánh để rồi Nó lại hơi bị
kiến thức kiến thức bài Buổi học nhưng
mà đỡ trả lời máu oánh đỡ trả lời hết sự
mới dồi đã em vừa rồi là đã lẽ là bây
giờ mới đến 8 giờ Bây giờ mới bắt đầu
buổi họp sự thời gian vừa rồi đó em về
buổi tâm sự nhưng mình lại nỡ trả lời
câu hỏi mất rồi Nhưng thương sao nhỉ
Chắc là các bạn sẽ lại được video đúng
không ạ ạ
Ừ có gì mình sẽ đánh mục lục lại cái
video là hôm nay mình học sớm hơn đúng
không
những các bạn vừa rồi nghe có hiểu thế
mà chắc cũng không đến nỗi đau não làm
đúng không ạ
anh
Quý giờ tâm sự bùa thôi hôm nay tôi
khẳng định ở hôm nay bây giờ bắt đầu học
này đưa mình sẽ bắt đầu với học xem mấy
ông mấy ông xem buổi hôm nay nó đủ dài
như nào chứ
Ừ ok
số chia
ở buổi học hôm nay như mình đã nói là
mình sẽ học về code và nghệ thuật xử lý
bác loud cho thì cái này lại cuối giờ
mình chia sẻ nhé Thì cái bootcd vào gì
cái vô review Nếu mà có bạn dịch ra nó
thủ tục mình khuyên các bạn không dung
dịch đấy đấy thế thế nên là bé lý do mà
các bạn nếu Để ý kỹ lại bên quét thì
mình vẫn còn dùng những cái từ tìm việc
tiêu đề tiếng việc còn sang bên bên này
thì không phải mình thích bằng tiếng Anh
hay là vì nó chuyên sâu nên mình để
tiếng Anh đâu mà bị không nên dịch dịch
thứ hai cũng là chẳng nhiều giữa các bạn
dịch thủ tục à Hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học
về thủ tục nghe nó cứ kiểu gì không ạ
kia à
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn sẽ phải hiểu
Australia nó để làm gì đã đúng không có
sẽ đi Hoàn chất nó là để mà rút gọn lại
toàn bộ những cái câu những cái câu mọi
câu của mình nó la la giống như mà hôm
trước mình học với view ở để rút gọn với
cấu xé rách hoặc còn phố sẽ bưu nó là ôm
tất cả của cdu các bạn chỉ cần uống đúng
mà cái này thôi đó là tôi sẽ đi có thể
làm tất cả
tin
tức là sao nó sẽ bao gồm cả select
Insert update Delete thậm chí là câu tạo
có lệnh tạo Bạc tất cả các câu lệnh đều
đều có thể nằm trong khối C đâu à Em
chào thầy hiệu trưởng em khuyên hiệu
trưởng nên hôm nay chịu khó ngồi học
cùng sinh viên bởi vì hôm nay cũng là
kiến thức mà thầy hiệu trưởng không biết
đâu và cái này hay cực
ừ ừ
I hear bây bây giờ để để mà làm quen rồi
cái về bố sẽ điều này cái đơn giản nhất
là sự bây giờ sự là mình cấp mình yêu
mình có sẵn bạn rồi sẽ sao phom sinh
viên em ạ
anh
không Hôm nay khoảng giữa giờ nữa Hôm
nay phải thầy hiệu trưởng phải đứng trên
tư cách của sinh viên luôn bởi vì thầy
hiệu trưởng cũng không Không biết cái
này đâu
ờ ờ Các bạn thấy thôi tại chung tặng tôi
chung là nhé để mà tí con hỏi nhá à
Ừ tí Mấy ông không kịp để mà nghe tôi
nói gì đâu các bạn thấy có bản sinh viên
là không ạ có mã tự động tăng này tên
người tình mạ lớp thì nhập đúng không ạ
Bây giờ sửa là mình Insert của bạn mà
trong bảng này chắc các bạn biết rồi ông
ạ Insert into
hiệu trưởng dự rồi mình phải ngoan mấy
ông thế chết người ông bao giờ thấy lớp
từng tự rồi chứ phải ngồi phòng tắm nhỏ
ạ
Anh
Tuấn hacker mũ trắng em ạ ạ
ạ bây giờ sự như thế này mà giới tính mà
không ngờ ạ mã lớp là một giả sử như thế
này ý sớm thì sẽ là các bạn quen quá rồi
với buổi này các bạn thấy có đơn giản
được cái này các bạn thấy là khi mình
chạy Xong nó không in ra được cái cái
bạn mà mình với giấc này cái thứ nhất
đúng không em
khi kết hợp với việc là là
kiểu dạng mà mình mụn Minh giờ xử mình
muốn xem lại lớp 2 mình muốn Giả sử mình
muốn xem lại đúng cái bạn sinh viên mình
mới ướt thế mình lại mất công mình copy
Đôi khi mình Hủy bỏ lại với câu chuyện
lần này để mà lấy đúng à Thì bây giờ
thay vì như thế này mình muốn tạo 1 cái
gọi là một cái cô sẽ lưu bản chất nó nếu
mà nếu các bạn biết lập trình nó giống
như một cái phong trần của cái hàm cái
hàm nó có thể bao gồm việc cả in xơ và
sẽ rách cùng một lúc chẳng hạn thì mình
làm nhà mình sẽ ra Kris
Vẫn là câu lệnh điều khúc của cái môn
này thì luôn có class đầu tiên này sau
đó tiếp theo tên của cái đấy này cái này
các bạn thấy là mình chỉ cần ghi đến
trước crocs và nó hoàn toàn là viết tắt
của chữ vô cdu rồi nhưng mà mình cứ ghi
đầy đủ các bạn nhé ờ
ờ thêm và
chị Chào bạn
đợi thêm Mày bị sinh viên nghe thấy
chứng minh rõ đi mình sẽ thêm ad ad hạ
áp ở đây này bị ghi này em này các bạn
luôn nhờ có đi khúc này nhá Mình học
trong cây em quê chứ sau luôn đều khúc
này crash này tên của cái mình đang một
lần này tên của cái
tên mình đặt tên cho nó đúng không ạ rồi
thêm chữ á này sobt vậy em nó kiểu dạng
điệp khúc nhà luôn rồi sau đó thì mình
sẽ copy cái này vào trong này đúng ngoài
và mình sẽ copy tiếp câu xe khách ở
trong này
anh không cần chấm phẩy hai gì trong này
nhưng mình sẽ hiểu lại khi mình tạo cái
này xong này tạm cái bô xe điều này xong
này thì bây giờ mình chỉ cần đơn giản là
mình ghi là skill e
a skilled
ex đúng nhạc
đúng mà
đợi đợi anh skill như này là xong lại
chạy này đó các bạn thấy là
thì rõ ràng mình không cần phải ghi lại
đầy đủ hai con này đấu Hoặc mình chỉ cần
gọi lại đúng cái video này là có như nó
sẽ tự động in xơ và kèm theo selects
đúng không
em thậm chí nó có thể ngắn hơn đó Cái
này không thể biết được đó thế này
các bạn Thậm chí còn ngắn hơn được nữa
đó là mình chỉ cần
đi bụi đen mỗi cái này bị chặn thì bản
chất là mỗi lần chạy cái này nó là cuộc
skill mà nó không ạ
Ừ
kệ tiếng Anh của mình đi mày Ông ngồi
bất này tiếng Anh đậu xanh tập trung tập
trung chim
thì ở đây thấy bài toán đó là Ok thầy
ông thầy chỉ cho em cái cũng rất là hai
kiểu là Ừ thì đỡ tốn việc gì
cho đỡ tốn việc là mình phải ghi lại coi
Insert mình có thể hoàn toàn là ai rót
và snack đúng không ạ nhưng mà rõ ràng
là các bạn thấy à bây giờ Vina đi Sốt
lại mỗi người như này sai đúng không Đây
mình đúng như bạn kia vừa nói là mình
phải cần truyền tên truyền tham số
truyền tên rồi tính mạ lớp vào đúng
không Đấy chẳng hạn thế Thì mình làm nhà
đúng không đấy các bạn bắt đầu song mắc
thấy đúng rồi đúng không Thì mình tạm
rút cái thằng vô CPU này đi đã Để mình
làm lại điều hòa tối của đi à
ạ sau đó thì lần này mình sẽ cho truyền
tham số vào mình sẽ cho truyền cái cái
biến khai báo biến hàm số ở trong này
thì nó sẽ là dùng a còn đâu mà chị sẽ là
tên này mình sẽ và mình sẽ phải quy ước
cái cái dữ liệu kiểu dữ liệu vào cái
tham số này thì dữ liệu của này thì nó
Nevada
rồi sẽ 50 em ạ sau đó thì giới tính này
cho biết này bà mã lớp này
kiểu in đúng không ạ Và ở dưới này mình
hoàn toàn chỉ việc thay thế mình copy
cái đoạn này rất là nhanh
Ừ bạn tên giới tính này mở lớp thế là
xong
ở đó thế xong rồi
thứ ba lần này để mà mình muốn truyền
các tham số vào để mà mỳ Ý sốt thì mình
chỉ cần cách ra với ghi tên bằng dụng
vào Long hay cơ mà Đấy xấu phẩy số tiếp
theo là giới tính
bằng 1 và bạn lớp bằng hai chẵn
sau đó thì các bạn thấy là sẽ sẽ được
đúng không
anh ở đây lại tiếp theo cái nữa
Ừ ok đến đoạn này thì các bạn ạ
nếu mà các bạn hình anh quá đi cứ vào
mình để mình chậm lại một tí nhé địa chỉ
các bạn thấy đoạn này Insert được rồi
mình có thể truyền các thứ thứ vào để
miếng sẽ từ hội các bạn vẫn thấy khó chỉ
có một điểm đó là nó không sẽ lách lại
được đúng cái bạn mà mình với giấc đúng
à đúng rồi Cái này rất giống hàm nó
chuyển động số không khác gì hàm cả
thì các bạn hoàn toàn có thể có nhiều
cách một là các bạn có thể slackware
theo đúng cái mạng lớp mà mình vừa mới
vừa mới Insert đúng không ạ
ở đây
ờ ờ quen theo đường bạn lớp còn nếu mà
các bạn muốn xé rách đúng cái mà bạn bạn
đầu tiên mình mới sợ thôi chẳng hạn đúng
không bạn đầu tiên thì các bạn nhớ ông ạ
Nó top 1 chẳng hạn đúng không Và mình sẽ
là Order bye mã PC về lấy bạn đầu tiên
vui nhất trở lại thấy đúng không Và
khi mình chạy thử lại nhé lại rốt vào đi
này
a Christmas nữa này
A và chạy lại này đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy
à cái đoạn này bạn chất là nó sẽ lấy ra
được đúng bạn đầu tiên mà mình vừa mới
vừa mới kiểu in sót xong ở
đoạn này các bạn theo kỳ ông ạ
Ừ
dạo này vẫn cơ bản đấy
ừ ừ
anh
alo các bạn trai theo kịp được đến loại
này rồi không ạ
Không không vòng Trời đang mưa đấy chưa
có anh không phải là ngồi gần nhà vệ
sinh độc
bây giờ mấy ông Kiều theo kỳ thì đưa tôi
bắt đầu nhảy sang cái khó hơn xác định
khó hơn Tạm tập trung nhé
Bây giờ giả sử mình lại sẽ lách lại thận
thì mình bị lười Lười ghi lại câu này
mình mình lười lắm Mình cũng không ghi
lại câu này cơ mình sẽ đổi lại cho các
bạn ở đây là sự mình đã cũng có thể
crash Hồi đấy tôi bị đổ lạm dụng crack
nocd và nhiều Cực ghi nữa em ạ
Ừ tôi cũng nhét sư cái này vào trong một
tôi sẽ đi luôn à
Nó là Xem sinh viên em ạ Đấy
anh như thế này sau đó thì tôi chỉ việc
anh chạy như này tôi sẽ celexa lại được
cái kiểu lừa như thế
Anh nổi tiếng heo là mình muốn Giả sử
mình muốn nữa
ừ ừ
ý mình muốn lấy Thay đổi là xử lý Thay
đổi cái bạn có mã bằng 11 sang tên khác
trả lại mà mình cũng kết hợp cô sẽ lưu
này tất cả sao là xưa ở đây nhá để mà
update một bạn sinh viên nữa các bạn
biết rồi đúng không xét tên bạn
ô
long quy biện ạ Where mã bằng 11 trở lại
đúng không Đấy như này
khi chạy Xong Các bạn thấy thông báo
thành công nhưng mà thứ ba cái thứ các
bạn cần không cần quan tâm được thông
báo thành công mà các bạn cần cần tìm
chị lại thậm chí ở hiển thị tên của bạn
đấy trước khi bạn ấy thay đổi là tên của
bạn đấy sau khi thay đổi nó là như thế
nào chả thế ngoài thì mình cần làm như
nào
ở rõ ràng tôi để đến Long hacker Nếu
không quan tâm tôi để nó Woa mày không
kỳ dị ngay ạ vậy chưa
đề
thi thì bài toán ở đây là mình cần tạo 1
cái code đó nhà mình cần truyền vào tên
chuyển tên và chuyển mã sau đó thì mình
cần cernex trước và sau khi update thay
đổi đồng hoa thì mình sẽ Express boat
sửa sinh viên ạ đấy để tên rất là dân dã
thì việc ở ngoài đấy mình sẽ có là
truyền tên cho nó này
nhờ vaasa
U50 chẳng hạn và chuyển mã cho nó đã tự
in này đều ngoan
ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ có ác bim hen sau đó
như mình ra xử ở đây mình sẽ có nhà
xem các bạn sẽ nghĩ rằng mình có thể
dùng Xem sinh viên của Where mã bằng còn
mãi nhưng không Không cái này không chạy
được bởi vì bản chất Cái này nó không
trả về nó không trả về cái bạn cho các
bạn để các bạn web như thế này thì các
bạn phải mất công phải sẽ rách sao form
sinh viên bạn như này were như thế này
có điều hòa
sau đó thì mình sẽ là update như thế này
cách
chèn thông tin vào như thế này do Hạn
Anh tên vào đây sẽ là mã này
và sau đó thì lại selects sao form sinh
viên phát nữa để xem trước và sau khi
cập nhật đó nó như thế này bơ lần này
các bạn chỉ cần tên bằng sự là Xem sinh
viên rồi tôi sẽ mạnh Xem sinh viên Xem
sinh viên nào như thế nào sự anh Tuấn mã
bằng hai được hạn tôi đổi anh đấy nốt
Thành Bưởi
Anh
Tuấn người bu chó đái phải mã bằng hai
máy ra xử như thế nào
ở đó thì các bạn thấy trước và sau khi
thay đổi nhỏ như nào
ừ ừ
các bạn này mấy ông
hiểu hiểu kỳ vọng
à à
Ừ
cái này vẫn chưa hết thì hai ông mà ông
cứ trật tự tôi sẽ giảm tiếp về những cái
hay của tao ấy à
ờ ờ
Ừ cái vừa rồi Ông thấy mấy ông thấy một
cái nhược điểm của cái Xem sinh viên vừa
rồi đó là Xem sinh viên vừa rồi của tôi
không dùng được
Anh không dùng được theo kiểu là tôi
phải mất công gõ lại cả cái đoạn này mà
rõ ràng là tôi muốn cũng truyền mã là
cũng tạm một cái vô siu đợi ở tỉnh gọi
đòn à
ờ ờ
cái đoạn này các bạn thấy là cái Xem
sinh viên vừa rồi ạ Xem sinh viên vừa
rồi mình không dùng được bởi vì à nó
không có truyền thêm tham số mã vào đúng
ngoan thì mình lại sửa cái Xem sinh viên
mình sửa đến tục đấy Nên là các bạn mà
xem đến cuối video các bạn chẳng hiểu
được cốt của ngày hôm nay đã cốc những
cái gì đâu nên các bạn phải loát rất là
kỹ từng cái đoạn mình nói xong là phái
hiệu để ngoặc ạ
Anh không nghỉ cuối Ví Dặm kiệm thấy này
dễ mà rồi quay đi quay lại thì có video
được chẳng hiểu gì cả Toàn Toàn câu lệnh
đi với chồng ghê gớm
đây mình sẽ có mã bằng đương nhiên là nó
kiểu này càng ạ sau đó thì que
mã bằng a Còn mã chẳng hạn ngay đúng ạ
thế này Ok bây giờ trong trường hợp này
thì mình hoàn toàn có thể sửa lại ở
trong này nó chỉ cần là ngày thôi
à Còn mã = a + mã trong nói hơi buồn
cười em đi mình hộ Minh chơi thủ bộ này
ý nghĩa vụ này chắc ở chạy được nhưng
mình chưa thử thử Phát
à à Anh nhìn trông lạ lùng nhỉ à
ở
chỗ nào mình tạo lại phố cebu này mình
sẽ lại dốt thế tôi CPU này phát nữa này
à
ạ sau đó mình sẽ copy thử cái này xem
chạy được
ở đó đúng rồi Cái này nên nó lỗi hào môi
này nếu mà các bạn muốn gọi cô sẽ đi nằm
trong code thì các bạn không thể ghi tắt
được như thế này bởi vì ghi tắt như này
khi các bạn ấn access này nó thêm chụp
oxy đoàn trước còn bây giờ là không nó
không thêm được rằng trước nên mình sẽ
phải tự thêm thủ công đó là ếch sách Tôi
sẽ lưu như thế này
em mới loạn này mã lúa à Giờ Rồi
ở đó thành công rồi đúng không Bây giờ
mới thêm lại này giờ mình sẽ đổi là mi
Pu đệ đi công chúa nữa rồi
ở đó
đúng giờ đây các bạn sẽ thấy cái À nó
cũng nó là cô sẽ lưu có thể gọi được
code ông ạ
A và các bạn thấy cho ra kết quả thì nó
vẫn thế thôi nhưng mà nó cách viết một
phát bị tạo hình mồ hôi xe Daewoo mới ra
hoa để gọi có sẽ lưu gì hết nhưng chưa
Cái này nó vẫn chưa dừng lại ở kể hai
cái hai này là vẫn chưa dừng lại đâu Cái
này bài toán là
Ừ Ok thế thì bây giờ giả sử mình muốn
xem sinh viên yêu mình muốn không chuyển
mã thì sao là như này các bạn thấy nó sẽ
bị báo lỗi bởi vì ở trong trường hợp này
nó bắt buộc nó bắt buộc và nó sẽ phải
truyền mã vào thì mình muốn cho nó 1 cái
mặc định mặc định gì đó đi ạ kiểu Dạ là
nếu trường hợp mà là
mình mình không truyền mã vào thì nó sẽ
lấy sẽ rách sao Thì sao
Thì mình có một cái không phải có một
cái khái niệm nó để for nhé mình sẽ cho
nó bằng một cái và Cái quan trọng là cái
defoe này sao cho mà để mà mình que theo
cái đấy
nó nó sẽ không nó sẽ lấy ra được tất cả
Ừ cái bạn này hơi bị lúm tí nhá
Đây nghe nghe nghe mình kỹ này nghe kỹ
mình đoạn này một tí nữa à
ở đây mình gom lại nhìn nó rõ này
khi mà khi mà chạy cái Xem sinh viên này
bây giờ mấy ông thầy nó báo lỗi là nó
bắt buộc phải chuyển mã đúng không Bởi
vì nó sẽ que thì cả mã đấy đúng không mà
bắt buộc phải chuyển Tôm muốn nó không
chuyển mã thì cũng được nó sẽ hiểu sẽ
rách sao mày hết chứ không cần que vùng
thì cả nữa đúng không Nói chỗ whey thế
nào để cho nó vẫn ra được kết quả được
điều hòa khi
ở cái đoạn Mã này nó phải bằng một cái
giá trị gì đó mà gần như là không không
có bạn sinh viên nào mã đấy ạ sử mình cứ
cho bằng -1 đi phát sáng là không có bạn
là mã sinh viên Ngoại trừ một sau đó thì
mình sẽ ở đây mình có một cái kiểu như
này
mã bằng trừ một kiểu này kiểu lách của
mình kiểu thứ nhất là mình sẽ cho nó mặc
định bằng - 1 sau đó thì trong trường
hợp mà mã bằng mã thì trả về kết quả
hoặc mã bằng -1 tức và mã mặc defo thì
cũng sẽ là snack sao cũng là select lấy
hết tất cả về hai mình thử chạy thử phát
nữa này
bạn làm đủ dài bắt đầu thú đấy
Sau đó các bạn thấy đến nó sẽ đến tất cả
đi thi cái khái niệm ở đây các bạn sẽ
thấy ra à Nếu mà cho bằng như này nó sẽ
hiểu đều vô nghĩa là mặc định khi mà con
không truyền vào thì nó sẽ tự nó sẽ lấy
giá trị này các bạn không cần một công
chuyện nữa đúng không ạ
em
cần giáo 5 phút để nguội lót không
ừ ừ
à à
khi
thầy hiệu trưởng Nga nghe thấy loại bỏ
cuộc rồi không thấy hiệu trưởng trả lời
chị nữa ừ
Ừ nó hơi bay nó không Tí đúng không ạ
à à
anh mãi mà kiểu bao xa á không mà ăn
kiểu bao xa đương nhiên là nó khác với
bạn mã kiểu và tra thì thì
đương nhiên là nó khó để cho một cái đi
phô
thì nó sẽ khó hơn à
à à
Ừ đúng rồi mình đi xong rồi cái defo nằm
ngoài cái giá trị mà nó sẽ không ngờ
dính vào gần như cái - 1 chẳng hạn đúng
không
à à
300 vậy Cái này các bạn phải thấy nó lo
nghĩa là một chiến mã Bằng chính cái mã
mình truyền vào nghĩa là nó ra sự trong
trường là về bọn - 10 ạ hoặc là -1 = -1
- 1 = -1 thì nó luôn đúng hoa và nó sẽ
ra được thôi
A2 - 1 = -1 thì nó luôn Đúng thế này là
nó sẽ bỏ qua cái cái cái que này và nó
sẽ lấy tất cả đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ nó bảo hôm nay sẽ thấy khó mà Mấy ông
thôi lại tiếp tục vấn đề nhé
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông bị sắp bị có tải Nói chung vào
hôm nay không quá tải không được máy bắt
buộc phải khó hôm nay không thể dễ được
dễ thì nó không phải vô xíu nhưng mà nói
chung nhà có ông nghe gì có bông cái cái
cái tô muốn truyền đạt ở đây là công sẽ
phải thấy nó hay để mà không chịu khó để
mà hiểu đúng ngọn chưa không phải thấy
nó vừa khó vừa chán thì ông sẽ bỏ đúng
không
Đấy thực tế như thế Cái này hay và cái
này cần phải hiểu sâu với nó cả AE trên
sâu này nó thế còn rất là cũng nó rất
rộng nó có thể hơi khó hiểu ban đầu
nhưng mà nó rất là hay để mà các bạn
thích tìm hiểu thêm thì tìm hiểu ý
Ừ cái này vẫn chưa là gì bây giờ tiếp
theo tiếp theo đây này đưa tôi sửa lại
cái shop này tôi sửa lại resort sửa
lại cả update thì mày ông bắt đầu mới
thấy lúa này
cho tôi bảo tôi sẽ sửa lại code của buổi
hôm nay mày không ạ thì bây giờ các bạn
Thể Ace sốt đã rõ ràng nhà
Ừ mình ra xử lý không muốn nhập giới
tính đúng không
vì mình không muốn nhập giờ ấy mà muốn
cho nó 1 cái đều vô mình có thể cho nó
đề for bằng 1 chẳng hạn đúng hoặc thậm
chí là mà lớp mình cũng thể cho đời
Phone nó là một tên thì mình không nên
cho Để for tên tên địa phủ
mặt nạ thật bây giờ đúng không Thì nói
cho mình sẽ cho nó 1 cái khâu như này
đúng không ạ
thì mình sẽ lại dốt mà đi Này mình lại
thì sợ nó lại đầu ngon ạ
ạ sau đó thì mình này trong trường hợp
này mình sẽ không truyền mấy cái này nữa
Mình chỉ cần truyền tên rồi cả bạn bánh
hacker mũ đỏ thì
nhà mình sẽ thử thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó
vẫn sẽ ra đúng không ạ À cái này do mình
chưa chuyển chữ N lần trước nên gà Nó
không
300 nghìn chị có dấu
đề thi cái bài toán ở đây thì cái này
thì ông thấy còn tương đối dễ đúng không
Nhưng mà tôi sẽ Tí tôi sẽ giao đề cho
mấy ông để cái này nó khó hơn một tí đó
là nếu trong trường hợp mà tôi không bề
bề đây để mấy ông tìm hiểu trước nhé tôi
không trả lời ngay trong cái cái buổi
này đâu bởi vì cô mà giảm luôn cái công
ấy trong buổi này sang máy bỏ bỏ không
xem nữa mất
cho đi phu
để phô mạc lớp nhé
là mã lớp đầu tiên của lậu là mã đầu
tiên của lớp đi
mà
Tại sao tôi phải nói cái câu đấy Ở đây 1
vì nếu là sử ông vừa rồi ông kiếp thẳng
luôn để cô là một đóng ạ sử thôi xóa xử
với lớp lớp 1 rồi thì sao đúng không ạ
con ngựa đau lớp đầu tiên của tôi mạo
lớp bằng hai bằng ba gì đó Thì sao Thì
cốt này của tôi sẽ lỗi đúng không Thì
bây giờ ơ Thực ra là mình giới tính thì
nó chẳng quan trọng nó không kiểm tra nó
không kiểm tra hơn phải tồn tại trong
mảng nào nhưng cái mã lớp này mình có
khóa ngoại ràng buộc với cái bảng lớp
thành ra là để cô của nó là chuẩn ra là
phải là cái một cái mạng lớp tồn tại đó
Ngoan thì mới chuẩn chứ không thể mình
ghi thẳng nó là một được bởi vì Nếu giả
sử mà
của anh vừa nói cô ấy xong lượng người
xem giảm và 56 người vậy chưa ta đi mình
mình sẽ phải a snack ra đúng cái lớp đầu
tiên đúng không lấy mã của lớp đấy thì
nó mới chuẩn
Ừ cái cái này mày ông hiểu đề của tôi
không ạ Khi cô ấy sẽ có xạo đấy à
từ
ngày mấy ông cứ thử một Mỹ trước đây à
không không không Đừng đừng đừng ngồi
nghĩnh đấy vội xuống xuống đây Cái này
đau lão này
đây Quay lại cái đến sửa nha à
có cây cây biến sữa này
anh không biết Tôi không nói lại một cái
đoạn nào đâu biết tôi nói lại hết xử với
học mất còn rất nhiều kiến thức cần phải
học à
ừ ừ
ở tận hai ông đòi nó lại rồi à
37 mèo bắt đầu lùi chưa
tôi tôi nó lại một lần rồi nhá á
Ừ để tôi sẽ nói lại à
a bắt bắt đầu từ đâu nhỉ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
đi theo đội hình biến nó lại lọ nào nữa
thôi có khi béo phải chấp nhận tua lại
đi qua xem livestream mày như tôi lại
được mà đúng không Mày không chấp nhận
tôi lại Xem lại nhé
ừ ừ
à à ý là nói lại cái đi Bye à đề bài là
là thay vì tôi truyền mã lớp bằng một
như thế này đúng không
Thì thì bởi vì cái mã lớp này bằng một
này đôi khi nó không đúng rồi Nhỡ đâu
giờ sự tôi xóa sử cái lớp có mã bằng một
rồi Đúng mà
và xử mã lớp tôi bằng 10 ạ ngon thì Minh
lại mất công và sữa cốt 10 không được Nó
nhà mình sẽ phải tạo một cái để phô
chuẩn là lấy mã lớp của lớp đầu tiên
là truyền vào trong đây để mà mình sẽ
luôn để khô khi mà mình về phô cho bạn
sinh viên đấy sẽ luôn là sẽ luôn đúng
chứ không phải bây giờ truyền lớp là một
này sau đó tôi xóa sự lớp 1 đi nữa hãy
nhớ kocu này cũng giống mới view nó là
Độc lập Độc Lập với bản thế này ra tôi
xóa cả bạn đi Xóa các bạn sinh viên xóa
làm bảng lớp đi cái pro CPU này nó vẫn
không bị xóa thành thì các bạn chạy nó
nó sẽ chỉ báo lỗi thôi chứ nó không bị
xóa đi nó không cho không cảnh báo nó
không Cảnh báo khi mà ông xóa bạn đâu
không phải là kia có một cô cdu nào đó
đang sử dụng cái bàn này bạn không được
phép xóa bạn không không không có như
thế có như là gặp nó độc lập với bạn
mình ra là ông mà xóa dữ liệu di cốt của
ông có thể không còn chạy được nữa không
ạ ra sự cố này là vẫn đang chạy được này
thì mà tôi xóa cái lớp mã bằng 1 đi thì
nó không còn chạy nữa đúng không Thì như
thế là không tốt cốt lập trình của mình
phải sao cho mà đến cuối
từ đầu đến cuối nó mình thêm cái gì em
mình sửa cái gì nó không ảnh hưởng đến
những ngày cốp cũ để Ngoan thế này là
chuẩn là default nó phải là một cái lớp
tồn tại được quá ừ ừ
Ý tôi nói thế Sao mấy ông hiểu được cái
đề bài thôi tôi sẽ nói ngang qua là
không phải nhanh tôi xin nói chậm qua về
cái vụ này Bây giờ ông vừa rồi thấy sửa
sinh viên giữa lòng Tên của nó là sự
sinh viên chúng phải sửa mỗi tên của
sinh viên đều ngoan Bây giờ tôi muốn sửa
rất nhiều cái của sinh viên thì mình làm
như nào thì cái đơn giản thôi chúng
ngoan vì truyền thêm dưới Đến
beat này mã lớp này
đi này đúng mà vẫn trông có vẻ rất là
đơn giản đúng không ạ
giới tính bằng
đã cầm giới tính
a tế à mà love
= a còng bạn lớp không cho mấy ông sửa
cả mã sinh viên đó nhé sửa mã sinh viên
để lỗi không hiểu mấy ông định sửa bởi
vì
nó Uh cho nó trong ngày đúng À đây mình
sẽ lại góp vào đi này à
khi mình chạy thử lại
ở đó thành công rồi đúng không ạ bây giờ
xử là như là nếu bây giờ mình sửa nhé
này thì nói hình sai này bắt buộc phải
truyền đầy đủ tất cả thông tin như này
và bắt buộc phải chuyển giới tính mà
chuyển mã lớp vào nhưng đây là cái thứ
mà mình đôi khi không muốn bởi vì Giả sử
Tôi muốn sửa tên của anh Tuấn thôi chứ
không sửa giới tính và mà lớp của anh
đấy mà tôi còn chẳng nhớ mã lớp lẫn cạn
dưới tính cũ của anh ấy là gì chẳng hạn
không nhớ giới tính cũ Hoàng cái với
khi thì cái đoạn này nó sẽ không đúng
không Thì ông sẽ vậy sao nó cái Ford
nhưng mà cái đề fo này phải ở cái đoạn
này nghe nghe kĩ nhá nó loạn này để sau
này lại phải lại là giới tính cũ và mã
lớp cũ của anh đấy chứ không phải là
không phải là cái giới tính ông cho đề
phủ đây bằng một đúng không
Đúng chưa ông cho đây bằng một đúng
không Thì thế này thì thế này thì say
những lịch sử tôi truyền như thế này rõ
ràng tôi sửa nhé Tôi sẽ thử nhé
ừ ừ
bài mới
à
nhầm nhầm
Thủ Thiêm ông sửa như thế này thì thì
thành ra là có nhiều
cái giới tính Ừ thì giới tính của anh
đấy mai vẫn là 10 và lớp là một thì hàng
ra ở vẫn giữ nguyên bây giờ sự anh lại
đang ở lớp 2 thì sao đúng không Anh ấy
đang ở lớp 2 tự như ông ngoại đuổi ông
ấy xa rất một đã bây giờ sự Anh ấy đổi
sang này lớp 2 nhé
Cái này không theo thứ tự với ông nhi
trước khi sao vẫn được nhá Tôi sửa này
đấy anh ấy xong thành lớp 2 đúng không ạ
Vì sao nó thì bây giờ tôi mà sửa mỗi tên
của anh đấy đúng không Mẹ quỷ em ạ Đấy
sửa nhé Tự nhiên lại đẩy người sang lớp
1 cứ mỗi lần Sửa tên anh đấy thì lại
quay đấy thành đều power không được đúng
không giữ nguyên những cái mà mình không
truyền vào khi phải giữ nguyên cái đấy
là một trong những cái tôi đã từng mò và
nó đau đầu hoa như thế này thì
ạ
bây giờ lại tiếp tục là các bạn không
nên cho một cái đề phô là cái
Ế
là là cái kiểu mặc định giá trị tiểu
ngày nữa mà mình thấy trong diffuse bằng
những cái thứ không thể xảy ra giống như
cái trường hợp snack vừa nãy thử Tôi ở
chợ đây tôi cho nó bằng
Ờ bit cho bằng nung mày ạ
Luôn nhá Bởi vì thực ra nó không để cho
chừa một chút nữa thì nôn là không không
có giá trị thôi Đấy giả sử ngay ra sự
ngay đúng không ạ
à à
Tải mình sẽ thử chạy thử cho các bạn
hình dung được các đoạn này nó bạn này
bắt đầu lo này
phải giảm kỹ bạn này không Nếu không
hiểu rồi
chị đã sửa tô cấp đổi giới tính của anh
đấy Bằng
Anh Bằng không đi đã Để cho công hiểu
ở
đây tính bằng không phải chọn
đây đúng không nhớ lúc mà tôi bỏ rồi
tính lại đi này mà tôi chuyển vào như
thế này
tôi không phải là tôi muốn truyền cái
giới tính của anh để biến hình luôn mà
tôi muốn bản chất ở đây đó là khi mà tôi
không chuyển được tính vào với tôm sẽ
giữ nguyên gửi tình cũ của anh đấy chia
đây mình sẽ có cái gọi lại ít Theo nó là
kiểm tra kiểm tra cái cái điểm tra kiểm
tra Nó tiếp theo ở trong lập trình còn
trong ngày nó sẽ khái niệm là cây When
là nó giống như là chồng mới xem ít em
nó sẽ bình thường là ít ví dụ là ít xong
rồi Kiểm cầu câu lệnh kiểm tra đúng
không kiểm tra điều kiện gì đó
sau đó gì nếu đúng này A Gọi e o là nếu
sai này trở nặng nề
BB lập trình đúng hoặc còn bên còn bên
Apple là nó viết thì còn lại cây quen
này rồi cũng đã kiểm tra điều kiện ăn
xong rồi nếu nếu đúng thì sẽ là làm gì
đó con eo Nếu sai thì cũng sẽ làm gì đó
như này thôi thì mình sẽ viết theo kiểu
điều kiện như thế đều ngoài
không trong ngày không nó cũng nó cũng
gọi sức ai Nhưng bản chất nó nó chuyên
về tiếp theo nhiều hơn hủy mình có chữ e
ở đây cây web Thì bây giờ mình sẽ cần
kiểm tra gì khi rơi tính là luôn thì
mình sẽ cho
giới tính này bằng đúng giới đến
anh nghe luôn heo
em heo là nghĩa là dưới tính tha luôn
không ạ thì sẽ là giới tính em em để
bóng cái cây quen này
em nhìn bạn này trông nấu kinh khủng mẹ
tôi chạy thử trồng mới nông sản
Em hãy giúp đi này
à à
Ừ
đúng nhỉ thì mình xem lại nhé em Giờ
tính luôn
à à đâu phải thêm chữ ren nữa xem đèn
bạn
Anh hello
ở đó
anh xuống dòng á Không cái này nên cùng
của dòng anh không nên xuống lòng nữa cô
Mỗi khi tôi viết để cho mấy ông dễ nhìn
cái này bắt buộc và lên trên cùng một
dòng dễ nhiều hơn
ở đó không thể truyền được giới tính mà
không cần chuyện gì nó vẫn lên không nó
sẽ cái bản chất ở đây nó gì nó là khi mà
các bạn không chuyển giới tính vào từ
tính sẽ ăn luôn đúng không và dự tính
làm luôn Thì nó kiểm tra đây Nếu nó là
nôn thì giới tính bằng của giới tính rất
là nó không thay đổi gì cả đúng
à Còn nếu mà mình truyền thẳng với tính
vào như này cho giới tính bằng 1 chẳng
hạn thì các bạn sẽ thấy là giới tính lần
này nó bằng mồ rồi nó không Tao là nôn
nữa thì giới tính sẽ được thay đổi bằng
cái được giới tính mình truyền bà thôi
thế được
ở đó xong
ở Tam vụ vi tính ảnh dễ tương tự với vụ
mã lớp này cũng thế mà lớp này mình phải
sau một cái số gì đó tương tự ứng ở trên
kia một con số mà không thể xảy ra trong
ạ Mình sẽ cho rằng - 1 em ạ bị tự động
tăng tự động tăng nó không thể bằng mộ -
1 hạn chế bằng không cũng được nếu mà
Mấy ông Két hay dấu trừ bằng không được
cho bằng không nhé là 10 số không có thể
xảy ra đúng không ạ đó sau đó thì mình ở
đây cây lại cây quen tiếp thôi
anh
với mã lớp bằng không ngờ bạn ạ
các
gen mã lớp sẽ bằng bạn lớp này Còn nếu
không thì mà lớp bằng mắt ở mình chuyển
vào này thế là xong
số chẵn
ở
đó Bây giờ Bây giờ thì các bạn thấy da
mặt lớp nó sẽ không Bây giờ mình thử
truyền mã lớp bằng hai và lại
anh như này nhé
về mặt lớp 1 Nhện hay này bởi vì xóa mã
lớp đi bị xóa cả người tình đi chậm ạ
chạy này
Ừ thì các bạn thấy là bạn lớp và giữ
nguyên tất cả mọi thứ giữ Nguyễn là sự
đây 123 thì thì anh ấy chỉ đổ mỗi tên
thôi rồi tính và mã rớt vẫn sẽ giữ
nguyên
à à
Ờ Ờ bạn kia đang nói ở ruộng vụ là nếu
có Trúc có lum Thì phải có rất nhiều cây
thực tế thực tế ở đây nhá Khi mà các bạn
làm bài toán thực tế các bạn không bao
giờ ngồi thủ công tạo người này ít em ở
trong Apple cây XL chuẩn nhất là làm ở
bên ngôn ngữ lập trình và các bạn cũng
hiểu bên đấy hơn thế này là Các bạn
truyền sang bên này chắc chắn trị dữ
liệu chuẩn thôi nhưng mình đang nói
trường hợp mà để các bạn hiểu rõ vì việc
kosala có thể làm được những gì không
cần ngôn ngữ lập trình nhỉ Các bạn thấy
nãy giờ không cài đặt ngôn ngữ lập trình
kiểm tra Intel về bản thân tôi sẽ đưa nó
kiểm tra được ít theo đúng không ạ kiểm
tra được à Lúc mình truyền vào lúc mình
không truyền thì như thế nào đúng không
Nó vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên kết quả và nó vẫn
sẽ trả về kết quả đúng ở đây đúng không
ở đây để cái mình đang muốn chia sẻ thêm
về phốt lưu lại được té mà các bạn học
trên trường ấy thì cô sẽ lưu các bạn nãy
giờ xong là xong Từ cái đoạn
thêm và hiển thị sinh viên này rồi qua
lấy mình được học đúng mỗi ngày thôi còn
không có nạn xe lách luôn chị ăn giả là
in shop-in-shop truyền đúng với tham số
vào là xong đấy thế xong thì thế nên là
khi nhưng mà các bạn sẽ không hiểu được
cái hay của bộ sưu có thể là mình có thể
thích thì truyền tham số lúc thì không
truyền hàm số thì nó trả về Kết quả nó
như thế nào đều ngoan
Ừ cái thứ gà chưa ở mức độ lũ đâu mẹ
không yên tâm
các bạn nhảy sang bên checker các bạn
mới thực sự là lúc cơ
à tiếp theo là mình đến cái delete
delete thì nó lại rất là dễ không ạ
Bên mình sang Delete nhá Nếu lấy là Tải
công anh
có cách nào để bỏ cái chân này đĩa thì
bản thân là các bạn hơn chữa skill thì
nó sẽ bỏ thôi
ở
đây như này thôi Chẳng qua là bởi vì ghi
kiểu này nói chậm nó không hiểu Cái này
là cái gì không ạ
ạ bây giờ sự tôi sẽ Delete nó ngoan
Delete thì mình đi lấy thì thường hay
Delete theo mã đúng không ạ thì mình sẽ
là mình tạo một class
1 code
xóa xinh viễn
mình sẽ truyền mã vào túi này
à à À thì ra là thực tế là riêng trường
hợp Delete này tôi không Tôi rất hiếm
cho mấy ông này cho cái trò là không
truyền mã và Xóa hết toàn bộ sinh viên
đi về Xóa hết toàn bộ sinh viên đi nó
trông là sai trái nhưng thực ra tôi chỉ
dậy người việc bạn thật sự là canxi form
xinh à đâu nhỉ Xem sinh viên đúng không
Excel Kill đợi bắt chước ma trước copy
code trên này đây mình sẽ lấy sinh viên
trước khi xóa này sau đó chị Ly platform
sinh viên này chẳng hạn đó ngoài của mã
mã bạn đúng không
sau đó thì mình
ý thức à ông sẽ lách lại thì nó trống ra
tôi nghĩa bỏ qua không cần được xe lách
lại đi điện xem đâu đấy các bạn chỉ cần
như này thôi đó thì đưa sự mình sẽ xóa
đúng ngoan quét mã bằng một nặng thế chị
sẽ là các bạn nhìn như này các bạn sẽ
hiểu lại xóa cái thằng mai mất cái thằng
này đi rồi đúng không
à à
anh
không mai kia thì nó vẫn có thể cho xóa
hết mà delete không có que vẫn chạy mà
nó chỉ là chị Cảnh báo rồi nhưng vẫn
thích nó vẫn thì xóa hết mà ừ
ở đó đó là đầy đủ tính năng về thêm sửa
xóa trong
về
câu nói học lại thêm sửa xóa đấy nha ngủ
ngon
vì thế mà được ra lại không đơn giản lắm
nhỉ
Ừ để mình xem xem còn cái gì khó của
TOSY ngoài nữa không
từ ngày tôi thực ra có ghi hết đầy đủ
đây rồi mày ông nhìn thấy cây quen nào
không đọc cái nó không biết mà
A Gọi bootcd lồng có video này
à à
Ừ Ừ
hình như chỉ thế thôi không nói khó lắm
à à
em
tranh thủ đấy Ừ thôi Cứ tưởng phải hơn
tiếng cơ cũng anh nhá Nhanh ấy anh không
được công có lĩnh hội hết được không Có
gì có ông có xe máy Xem lại video nhé
Thì cái cái bài này Tổng tổng kết lại
thì các bạn sẽ thấy tác dụng của đu đúng
không ạ Không phải viết lại câu truy vấn
này máy chạy nhanh hơn bởi vì biên dịch
câu truy vấn tôi và mình chỉ cần Chạy
ngắn gọn cái cái cái vừa nãy đúng ạ bảo
mật à bảo mật hơn bởi vì cái quan trọng
đó là
đó đó là các bạn với thấy rõ ràng mà
mình không biết được cấu trúc của cái
bản gốc nó là cái gì mình mình cứ truyền
mấy cái mình cần truyền mà thôi chứ thực
a mình không nhận biết cái ví dụ rồi các
bạn chạy mỗi câu này hay ở trại câu sửa
hay như này chẳng ạ Các bạn chỉ cần biết
được là ừ thì mình truyền tham số là tên
chưa 5 số La Mã Nhưng mình đâu biết được
là cái bảng đấy tên là gì Bạn cái tên là
sinh viên là cô sinh viên tên là student
tiếng Anh là ngon cột các bạn cũng hỏi
cục tên cũng không phải cột mã các bạn
sẽ không biết là điều đấy nên cái này
liên quan đến bảo mật cái này còn bảo
mật hơn ở một điểm giống như buổi đầu
mình còn nói đó là lập trình viên mình
thực tế Không được phép chạy hẳn câu
lệnh Delete Insert update vào trong trực
tiếp bảng đối ngoại bởi vì nó rất là
nguy hiểm nên thường là nhiều công ty
lớn nó sẽ tạo cho mình những cái code
như thế này và cho các bạn truyền tham
số và thôi bà nó kiểm tra rất chặt ở cái
đoạn phốt lưu này để đề mà kiểm tra xem
là kiểm tra xem và kéo các bạn
thì các bạn có được phép làm cái đấy
không đấy ông ạ dù là sử đây nhá Sửa Đây
là các bạn thấy à update ở đây ra sử
dụng mình không cho mình không cho
update mà lớp chẳng hạn bị xóa ngay đi
em ạ thì thì bây giờ giả sử mình truyền
mã lớp vào như thế này mặt lớp bằng hai
như thế này thì nó chẳng có tác dụng gì
cả nó không chạy được chia làm đôi có
chạy được của vì bạn thân cái trong kocu
này không update mạc lớp đúng không Thế
này giờ tốt với cả bảo mật à
khi sex
I could reduce nó là không giới hạn các
bạn chạy được nhiều bảng thậm chí là tạo
được cả bạn Ảo bây giờ mình sẽ nhắc qua
một tí một cái cái này kiến thức mới nó
hơi hay mình tí Nó không không cần các
bạn phải các bạn chỉ cần biết thôi không
cần các bạn áp dụng lắm đó thực tế Đó là
các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn biết cái vụ là
tạo bảng Ảo thứ tự Ảo nó là gì Ví dụ là
sự mình sẽ tạo bạn sinh viên như này em
ạ Đấy sinh viên như bình thường nhưng tự
nhiên vì thêm cái giàu sang làm trước nó
không phải lỗi nó không phải cách mình
đặt tên nó thế mà đây là tạo cái khái
niệm tạo bằng Ảo cái tạo mảng ảo này tất
cả Sao mà khi mình mắc kết nối cái cơ sở
dữ liệu này cho rằng là mình tắt máy đi
hoặc là mình bắt cái cái này đi này thì
từ từ nó sẽ tự động ngắt kết nối những
cái server thì cái bảng ảo này sẽ lập
tức bị biến mất toàn bộ những cái phao
tác liên quan thì các bạn nào này giống
như là Tạo
cách tạo Index này hay tạo kiểu tạo view
Hay tạm Toshiba cho nó độc lập với bảng
không nói gì nhé à anh nói Trung Hà thêm
nhiều bản ghi và xanh vào này khi nó sẽ
bị xóa sạch khi mà ngắt kết nối Và thậm
chí cái này còn khai nữa đó là khi mà
các bạn tạo bảng nào Ngay trong code Trì
anh không còn bằng ảo không phải view
nhé Đấy ông bị nhầm đợi thì mình là nốt
thì cách tạo Bảo à trong force you là
khi mình kết thúc phải vô sẽ điều này
nghĩa là oxy điều này chạy Xong rồi cái
bàn nào này cũng sẽ bị xóa luôn sẽ không
còn ba nào nữa Đây mình cứ ví dụ Các bạn
xem nhé
Khi bữa nãy anh em mình tặng bạn ảo là
một rồi thì tên bằng pháp bà là hay đi
ra sự nha à
ở
tại Mỹ in search into
bị copy ở
e-blue Nó là một năm trở lại sau đó xex
sao
form2 à
thì mình nghĩ là mình cứ copy hẳn ra một
cái fotouri
ocd là tạo bạn nào xem nào
bugi này e này mình sẽ có cái tạo bạn
nào này đúng ạ Mình sẽ có như này ổn rồi
không ạ Sau đó gì bây giờ mình thật sự
mình chạy cái này các bạn thấy là nó sẽ
lách được như thường như như có một cái
bàn không ạ nhưng bây giờ là sử các bạn
selects lại phát nữa ở ngoài cái boot
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó không có vậy
bản này vì bản chất cái bảng này nó chỉ
tồn tại trong Đúng vô sinh viên này thôi
Đúng rồi nó giống thì sang bóp tòa kiểu
khi mà ngắt kết nối nó sẽ toàn bộ dữ
liệu nó sẽ bị xóa đâu ạ
thì cái view nó khác hoàn toàn rồi
review nó là mà review bản chất nó là
làm một câu select trên trên nhiều trên
nhiều bảng hay là chọn chưa salad gì đó
đúng không em
đừng ngồi có thể gọi bạn lô cô bạn của
lô bộ người ra đây không đúng cũng không
hẳn đã đúng lắm mà việc cái này có thể
là tạo ở ngoài tôi sẽ lưu không ạ
I Mục đích để dẹp thì hoàn toàn là các
bạn muốn tạo dâm cái dữ liệu nhanh thì
các bạn test sau đó thì khi là ngắt kết
nối thì xóa hết dữ liệu này đi đồ ngoại
ví dụ làm mình già xử Giống như mình đi
dạy học này thì ra là mình hoàn toàn thể
tạo rất nhiều cái bảng sinh viên ảo để
mà buổi sau mình đỡ phải mất công dốc
Cái bàn này đi Mình đọc thì mình tạo một
cái bạn trùng tên không ạ Đấy mình không
cần lại đặt tên là sinh viên ngồi sinh
viên hay nữa hoa mình cứ hôm nay mình
tạo một bảng hôm sau tạo lại bảng tên
giống hệt cũng được bởi vì mình ngắt kết
nối là nó xóa và người đi rồi mà đều
ngoan ý
à à
Ừ đấy thì nói chung là hôm nay thật là
hơi nhiều kiến thức rồi đúng không mình
à
Cho
mình xin phép chuyển qua cái kệ thử đã
cái này nó vui nhưng mà lòng đau não này
Ê mấy ông tặng phạm Lát lại một tí đã
nhé
Ừ cái này nghe cho vui thôi mày ông nghe
cái đoạn này nó cũng
Ừ nó cũng hay nhưng mà nó cũng cũng mới
anh à Mấy ông cũng phải mất công Tải não
đấy
tôi dậy hôm ấy ông tôi còn thấy đau não
nữa bởi vì tôi mấy ông thì phải nghĩ để
hiểu con tôi phải nghĩ để sao cho rằng
nó dễ đây là tội thế âm được lắm đơn
giản gì đâu ạ
Anh đang chơi 5 phút à Thôi tạm chấp
nhận bởi vì mấy ông bây giờ môn Toán thì
tao lại Xem lại sau mà nó như ý
à à
Anh ở chung nhà mình sẽ nói qua cái này
cái này rất là hay cái thứ ca nó liên
quan đến bên bên công nghệ công nghệ là
nhiều cái bài toán xử lý là nhiều nhưng
cái này liên quan đến cả cái thứ mà về
sau mình sẽ có học đó là cái chi cơ
nhưng mà mình cảm thấy là nó khá phù hợp
ở bên database này nên mình mới giới
thiệu cho bộ hôm nay đi
ý thì cái chích cơ đầu tiên các bạn phải
hiểu trích thơ nó là gì đã chích nơ Nó
là kiểu là nó là cò súng nhé mình dịch
thu nó thế nó có súng nhưng mình không
nên dịch kiểu như thế mà chi cơ thì các
bạn sẽ hiểu là khi mà
và đặc biệt mấy ông nào biết một tí
tiếng Anh không hiểu mới được cái từ chỉ
cơ này hơn những kiểu khi tôi chửi ông
Xong rồi ông giật bắn lên màu như kiểu
bánh lại tôi ý thì tôi vừa chi cơ ông
kiểu như thế Mẹ tôi và kích hoạt Ông làm
cái độc làm một cái gì đó phản ứng lại
với chỉ cờ khái niệm nó lắm phản ứng lại
khi mà có video tác động vào
ừ ừ
em chỉ khi khi mà làm cái phần mềm
thường là sẽ có hai loại chị cơ thường
thường 2 loại chích cơ khi có khái niệm
một chiếc cơ là phi cơ là gọi lại even
bằng chiếc ơi chị có scandal kêu chích
vợ Y Vân nó Gì cái này nó kiểu như này
đây Thực ra anh này có nói đề cập tới
đây rồi đó là khi các bạn đăng kí đăng
kí tự nhiên lập tức các bạn được gửi
mail thông báo là bạn ở đâu đăng ký
thành công này đúng không ạ hoặc là khi
các bạn đặt đặt đồ xong lập tức là nó
gửi tin nhắn về là tài khoản bạn vượt An
toàn bao nhiêu tiền em ạ Cái đấy gọi là
chiếc even
Ừ cái đấy Tại sao gọi đi ven bờ Việt nó
ngẫu nhiên các bạn hoàn toàn không biết
được là
cái cái cái trang web đẩy còn còn không
biết được bạn bạn mấy giờ các bạn đặt
hàng cả đúng không ạ Các bạn chị đó là
lên Đạp thì nó mới bắt đầu mới gửi mail
các bạn chứ không phải là nó cứ đúng 3
giờ nó gửi các bạn cái mail không phải
như thế Không ạ Các bạn làm xong mới đi
đó thì nó mới bắt đầu gửi cho các bạn
một cái gì đó thì cái đấy à Chứ given
con cái chích girl skardu tất cả lên
lịch lên lịch và nó chạy hàng ngày hoặc
là hàng tuần gì đó đã theo kiểu lạ ví dụ
là cưng một tháng thì các bạn lại gửi
mail spam quảng cáo cho người dùng một
lần nào nặng thì đấy gọi là chi cơ về
scandal là lên lịch đều ngoan thì
ý thì cái bài toán về cái chiếc even thì
nó xảy ra đơn giản như thế này giống như
các bạn đang xem video của mình trên
YouTube Đúng không ạ thì là sự Cứ mỗi
một ông bấm vào xem thì được nữa luật
người xem tăng lên 1 chẳng hạn đối ngoại
thì cái sức vơ đấy chứ cơ Y Vân Tại sao
vì nó là không phải cứ đúng rồi lược
lượt xem nó tăng mà phải khi có tác động
vào đó ngoan thì nó mới bảo tăng thì cái
bài toán ở đây nó sẽ rất là phiền khi mà
giả sự là có 1.000 người giả sửa đấy Anh
có 100 ông vào xem cùng một lúc thì nó
phải câu chạy câu lệnh update cái cái số
lượng Xem tăng lên mụn 100 lần liền đúng
không các bạn sẽ thấy là cực các bạn học
về đã ta bây rồi Các bạn thấy Giả sử có
một bảng là bảng bảng Video xong rồi có
đếm số lượt xem để không ạ rồi Cứ mỗi
lần một người vào xem thì có phải là tạ
nó nó kích hoạt cái chích cơ đấy để
update Ừ cái bảng này tăng lượt xem lên
một đúng không Thì bây giờ có 1.000
người cũng xem thậm chí Ông đang ngồi
livestream ông con lên đến triệu người
vào cùng xem đúng không ạ thì thành ra
là nó lên 1 lọ update 1 triệu câu lệnh
thì vỡ mồm đồng ăn thì giải quyết bài
toán ở đây đó là gì thứ nhất là cái quy
tắc của xử lý đó là là một là các bạn áp
nếp xong rồi mấy hiển thị cho người dùng
cái lượt xem Đấy là sử là bây giờ mình
vào một cái một cái ý Kiểu kênh một cái
kiểu phim này chẳng hạn đúng thì các bạn
thấy là vào loạt rất là nhanh rõ ràng mà
nếu mà nó mà theo kiểu theo cơ chế là nó
phải mất công up date update lại rồi nó
mới hiển thị ra cái ở đây là bao nhiêu
lượt xem khi nó phải mất thêm thời gian
để mà đợi câu lệnh nắp đến để chạy xong
đã rồi nó mấy người thì video này kết
hợp với cái tổng lượt xem ở đây cho cho
mì từ nhỏ không nó sẽ làm theo cơ chế là
ok tao sẽ ghi lại cái hành động Mày vào
xem nhưng mà tao sẽ update dần dần sau
để tránh bị quá tải cũng như là để cho
người dùng hiển thị ra trang web mà
nhanh không phải mất công đội là update
xong rồi mấy hiển thị trừ khi đấy là
những thông tin rất quan trọng cần phải
fb xong thì mới thông báo khách Hạ con
cái này hiển nhiên à nó không quan trọng
ví dụ lượt xem được là nó không hẳn quan
trọng bắt buộc phải chính xác có bao
nhiêu lượt từng lượt xem1 liên tục thì
nên là
Vì thế nên là hoàn toàn có thể đẩy vào
khái niệm là chó tất cả nó chạy Nến và
chạy sau Nó có thể là cư đẩy Giống như
mình mình mình đi
A Gọi gọi nhá như thế này thuộc dạng là
kiểu ông đi mua một cái điện hoạt đúng
không không đưa tiền người ta có thể là
ông nếu mà ông muốn lấy cái điện thoại
luôn thì đúng là thằng kia nó phải mất
công vào kho Tìm điện thoại nó đưa về
cho em còn nếu mà ông theo kiểu là ông
không quan trọng cần lấy luôn thì ông
hoàn toàn trả tiền thanh toán thằng kia
thông báo Ông thành công trước ông cứ về
nhà xong rồi thằng xong ngồi cái cửa
hàng đấy nó sẽ đưa cho một nhân viên là
con chó nó sẽ nó sẽ thu lại toàn bộ
những nó sẽ thu lại tất cả các đơn của
ngày hôm đấy Xong rồi nó đi phát lần
lượt đúng không Thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ hôm sau mới dậy cơ thực ra hôm nay
thì cũng chị giới thiệu qua các bạn hiểu
na ná chứ có nói gì chứ cũng có nhắc gì
chích cơ buổi sau sẽ học đâu đó ạ
Ờ thì cái cái việc ở đây xảy ra ấy đó là
ok Thì thực tế là trải nghiệm nó sẽ tốt
hơn cả là hiển thị ra được luôn giao
diện Đỡ phải mất công đợi ngồi đợi
update bao nhiêu thằng cùng một lúc mà
mình sẽ chạy nền cái vụ đấy nhưng mà nó
có bị nhược điểm ở
đó là như mình vừa nói 1.000 người truy
cập vào cùng 1 lúc là 1000 câu lệnh áp
lên chỉ để tăng lên một thực ra là nó
cũng rất là nhiều Đúng mà nên là cái bài
toán xử lý ở đây là kết hợp hai loại
tiếp hợp hai loại đó là sao
ở đó là ông có 7 sao thằng nhân viên ông
khi bị và thằng nhân viên đấy nó sẽ lưu
lại vào trong cái cách và lưu lại trong
kho là số lượng đơn các thứ thứ
anh ở đây ở đây tôi thử thử ví dụ lại về
cái vụ mua cửa hàng kia vừa nãy nhắc đây
nha ông buồn cái điện thoại đúng không
anh thì OK anh không cần phải đưa cái
điện người ta đưa do mới điện thoại luôn
đóng thì về nhà ông đợi đúng không Thì
chị cái cửa hàng ấy sẽ bảo một nhân viên
của họ để mà cá nhân viên này nó sẽ đi
đưa cho ông nó không thì nếu mà nhân
viên đấy nó đi đưa cho ông một đơn mà
mất Một yên viên thì giờ sự hôm đấy có
rất nhiều đơn thì có nhân đánh nhân viên
thì không đầy đủ đúng không và kết hợp
việc là là
cứ một nhân viên thì chạy một đơn như
thế sau đó thì lại về nhà xong rồi lại
lấy cái đơn tiếp theo để chạy thì rất
mất công chúng ạ thì nó sẽ có cơ chế nhé
nó cứ đưa nhân viên nhân viên cứ tống
hết toàn bộ đơn này vào trong cái kho
sau đó thì thỉnh thoảng cứ một tiếng sau
một tiếng sau thì nhân viên ship thẳng
hạt nhân viên sẽ lấy hết toàn bộ những
đơn trong kho rồi đi phát luôn một lần
một lần rồi thôi đấy Kiểu như thế Thế
cái bài toán ở đây nó nói lại với cái
bài toán về Cập số lượt view của video
này thì 1.000 người cùng vào xem thì nó
sẽ nó sẽ không update 1000 câu truy vấn
và DB mà nó sẽ lưu lại 1.000 cái xem đấy
vào trong trong một cái kho thổi đúng ạ
Sau đó một tiếng sau một tiếng sau nó
mới lấy toàn bộ số lượng xem ở trong cái
kho lấy nó cập nhật một câu vào trong bê
thôi ví dụ là tiếng trước thì 1.000 được
xem thì nó cập nhật + nên một nghìn
không ạ tiếng sau giờ sự chỉ có 100 thôi
này nó chỉ cần cập nhật cộng 100 thôi
Thấy nên là các bạn phải là video trên
YouTube nhiều lúc các bạn vào lượt xem
nó không ngờ đúng là sự có nhìn người
vào xem đỡ xem nó chỉ tăng chị khó khăn
mình nhớ không lầm tình yêu nó cứ cho
một con số quy ước người hướng ra 300
bao nhiêu ý vì gì đó ngoan xong rồi sau
một tiếng rau hoặc đội thiếu một ngày
sau nó bắt đầu cập nhật
an toàn bộ những cái ý cái đấy đúng
không
Ừ đúng rồi mấy ông cũng hiểu vấn đề
ngoan có nhiều bạn gặp rồi đó à Rõ ràng
cái video nó bị đứng bị đứng lượt xem để
ngăn
không Cái vụ lưu hỉ nhiều nên nó lưu một
kiểu cách thì đúng cách thì cũng có
nhiều chỗ nhiều cách lưu mà có thể lưu
hẳn trong đêm dp có thể lưu và màng gì
đó vân vân à Nhưng cái lưu này là lưu số
bạn ghi chứ không phải cập nhật và học
cập nhật nó mới nặng còn lưu lại thì các
bạn không bị nặng Lưu nó không quan
trọng nhưng nó không kiểm tra thì là nó
không nặng
Ừ đấy thì các bạn thấy là cái này thứ da
có mụn có bị một nhược điểm giống như
các bạn khó đang đang nói đó là tự nhiên
bị đứng lượt xem nó không ạ một vì cái
này trải nghiệm người dùng đôi nó tốc độ
thì nó giờ nhanh một vì tốc độ thì người
dùng nhìn thấy được ngay cái video đúng
không giống thể xem được video nhưng mà
nó khó chịu vì cái việc là người dùng
trải nghiệm người dùng không tốt đúng
không Bởi vì nó có delay nó có độ trễ
kiểu người dùng sẽ có chịu đấy Nên là
cái này người ta phải cân nhắc việc việc
kiểu ạ Nếu mà trên YouTube này thì nó
đang chấp nhận bài toán là là nó muốn
người dùng Xem video nhanh nó không quan
trọng lượt xem thì nó toàn thật lâu lâu
nó mới cập nhật lại video một lần
Ừ cái kiểu như thế không
Ừ
nếu nãy giờ nghe khó hiểu mấy được xem
tự nhiên tăng hơn hạn trả mấy ông bị vì
ông bế web bây giờ bắt đầu vào đấy nghe
nghe lòng ạ ạ
bộ phim
Ừ ok tiếp theo là để vụ gửi email thông
báo hàng loạt vừa rồi thì mình có đề cập
với vụ là nó là Ivan chức cơ tức là là
kiểu khi mà
nó sẽ là ngẫu nhiên ngẫu nhiên không
biết được lúc nào nó được update đúng
không ạ Con
Ừ lúc nào là cái chi cơ được kích hoạt
mà còn bây giờ đến suz cơ tức à Kiểu dụ
là hàng tháng ông gửi gửi thông báo cho
một triệu khách hàng cùng 1 lúc đóng
ngoặc để bạn quảng cáo mà ngạnh không ạ
thì
cái cái ở đây nó bị nhược điểm đó là
thời gian xử lý rất là lâu bởi vì một
triệu người cùng một lúc mà ông ngồi
spam spam thì hướng nghiên ạ sẽ mất rất
là lâu Đúng không Nó thể chết luôn mà
server của ông bởi vì nó chạy nó mà bị
cháy trong một khoảng thời gian liên tục
như thế đâu mà bị quá tải thì nó sẽ bị
nóng hoa nó sẽ bị chết con sợ vợ và cái
thứ hai là khó ghi trai ở từ anh này tự
nhiên dùng kính lông dùng tiếng Anh luôn
Tùng tiếng Việt lúc cả anh ta biết cái
đôi khi tao hơi khó chịu với vụ đấy một
là dùng hết tiếng Anh hay dùng hết tiếng
Việt trong một câu là khó thử lại để nó
dịch là như thế nghĩa là ấm chị ạ là sử
là ông nhớ nhau đến thằng thứ
9900 tự nhiên nó bị chết cái gì đó đúng
ngon server của người đó chết thì uống
này phải bấm gửi lại thì đương nhiên là
có thể lại phải gửi lại từ đầu rồi những
mẫu đang chơi cơ chế là gửi một lần như
thế này là ông ngoại gửi lại từ đầu lại
gửi cho một triệu nữa thì có những ông
sẽ nhận được hay email đầy ngoạn chỉ 34
email đấy chơi thế thế cách bất nông dân
hơn đó là ông thay vì ông gửi đồng loạt
cùng 1 lúc ông sẽ đẩy là lượt cho từng
con giáp con giáp
anh từng con những nhân viên một về con
để mỗi con nhân viên là một mail hay là
mười mail thì gì đấy thì cái bài toán ở
đây nó hay ở điểm là thì sao bộ ông sẽ
nhẹ từng con chạy một và con nào chết
thì chỉ ảnh hưởng có đấy thôi con đấy
hoàn toàn bị chạy lại đúng loại thì nó
sẽ đỡ việc là con này ảnh hưởng con kia
đúng không
anh
nghe nãy giờ nếu không hiểu gì không ấy
ạ
anh alo
ở màn hình cái cuối này cái cuối này là
một trong những cái khó nhất cái này đau
não này đúng nghĩa ở đâu nào mình đọc
lúc đầu mình không hiểu
ừ ừ
Anh ở trong lập trình viên bọn mình cái
gọi nó cách nông dân không vậy trên nông
dân đâu Mà gọi cách nông dân rất là cách
kiểu nó bị thủ công bị kiểu dạng mà
không áp dụng nhiều công nghệ không ăn
dụng Tân Tiến ý kéo còn rất là kiểu còn
nhớ chứ thụ gọi là sơ sài sơ khai kiểu
kia thì mình không biết dùng từ diễn tả
như thế nào nhưng mà cái nông dân Nó
kiểu như thế nó kiểu cách nó kiểu tối
giản từ
nãy giờ ông không hiểu cái gì
Anh cho em xin link mà biết à ông trả
tên là ra mà thấy ông con để có thành
địa chỉ đấy cha mà nó vẫn là trình
keep-or-drop thôi
Ừ cái này cái cái cuối này nó lại giữa
là cái hay nhưng mà nó cũng sẽ khó hơn
này nói chung nói chung là tôi đọc những
bài này những có những bài Thực sự nó
giờ khó thật và cần phải làm lâu rồi mới
hiểu được cái đấy thì thì tôi không thể
chia sẻ cho mấy ông được nhưng cái này
thì tôi nghĩ là có thể chia sẻ được Có
thể bây giờ ông chưa hiểu Nhưng mà ông
hiểu đúng phần thôi và ông nhớ được Nhớ
được mấy cái khái niệm này để về sau ông
có thể làm kiểu gì Tôi tin là về xong
Làm lập trình làm dân công nghệ mấy ông
kiểu định về sau sẽ tiếp xúc mấy này và
mấy ông sẽ hiểu điều bạn cũng sẽ hiểu
hiện nay và mình thấy à Ôi cái này nó
giải quyết được bài toán thực tế của
mình anh đúng không mà Đây đây cái cuối
này Cái Quế thì mình không cần nhựa rất
ít không bao giờ không bao giờ làm nhưng
mà tôi sự nói qua và ông ấy cái vụ này
à À không Tuấn Tuấn nghĩ lại rồi Tôi
nhìn lại Đồng Nai Tôi muốn giải thích
cho mấy ông Tôi không biết trả lời ông
như thế nào nữa à
để hỏi tội nghĩa cái cuối này thì chắc à
Vì ông vì sau làm nên con này đang tới
bây giờ mày ông chân sau và ta được Bởi
ông sẽ hiểu được
cái hình này mô phỏng cái gì em ở chỗ là
tạm thế không ai buổi họp hôm nay nó rất
là nú đúng nhỉ theo kiểu là đến cả cái
bà chia sẻ của nó mức độ khó nó cũng
tăng lên nhưng mà mình Hi vọng mà từ
tuần tuần sau
ngoan tuần sau thì sẽ
thì các bạn sẽ còn hơn một tuần à còn
đúng là tuần để các bạn có thể ổn các từ
thứ để máy hiệu này mà không ạ bài tập
hôm nay thì mình nghĩ à không có tương
đối thôi làm lại cái đống bài hôm nay
mấy ông xã đủ quá tải rồi à
đã tạo nên thế nhá bây giờ cũng chỉ ra
rồi mà không
Hi xin chào các bạn có thắc mắc gì không
nhỉ
ở đại mấy ông kia bắt đầu máu đau não
rồi kìa thôi muốn mỗi ngày chỉ cần nghe
10 mà hiểu 56 thôi triệu là 56 còn siêu
ấy hiểu Ba Buồn thôi rồi Từ từ còn hiểu
tiếp nhỉ
Xin
chào các bạn nha tương lai Nhìn Đỗ
ừ ừ